derrick holland gets to start it here
this afternoon
goodroom turns on one sends one to deep
left that ball is gone a home run for
nico goodrum to lead off this saturday
afternoon and it's one nothing detroit
here's miguel cabrera
yo two lifted to left
carrying deep and history
a two-run blast from miguel cabrera and
the whooping sticks have come out here
in the first for detroit on time he
really stayed out of that he's a little
early but he keeps himself back cj crone
stands in three runs home
big swing on this one to deep right
center come on it's out of here derek
collins looking like what's going on
i'll tell you what's going on
the tigers have three homers in four
batters they call that hot first game
with three homers in the first inning in
three years here's jamer candelario
oh and he launches one to left
that ball's deep that ball's gone are
you kidding me
no this is incredible
first pitch swinging into the left field
seats i mean he leaned all over he got
to saw this ball good looking he leans
on it
candelario's first homer of the season
buckos they trail five nothing to the
detroit tigers bearer steps to the plate
for the second time
oh yeah
hot shot
and it's an out gonzalez was able to
hold on to that the ball stayed on top
of the glove
and then he was able to hold on to it
that's an out so eight hits for detroit
and puts two on with two out for travis
demerit here's the 3-1
oh and he laces it to left
reynolds
will throw it it'll be not in time to
get scope
tigers add on another
they're up by a half dozen
travis demerit with his third rbi of the
season
sat back nicely on that one
detroit grayson griner
greiner takes strike three second
strikeout for derek holland here today
the 2-2 got him looking derek holland
back on track six nothing the detroit
tigers lead the pittsburgh pirates here
in the third inning kevin newman
that one head out to center jones had
him shaded toward right center
and that'll clang off the wall dyson
will be in easily
stallings will make it to third on that
rbi double for kevin newman and the
pirates have one on the board
walt was flying get the ball in the air
is going to the wall or over
newman crushed it off the center field
walls
josh bell
rolls one to second they'll get the run
home it's 6-2 but two away chip away you
don't have to score six runs in one
inning detroit with a six to two lead
two on with one out
and rolled through the right side base
hit
reynolds got a good jump throws going to
come to third
safe
ball got away
and dyson will scoot into second
reynolds is in and the pirates make it
six to three on the hit by gerard dyson
now the tying run at the plate
that goes to the backstop
here comes evans to the plane and the
bucks have another you're in third just
going to read it most of the time the
runner is going to beat the pitcher to
the plate three hits already today for
kevin newman
and newman comes through with a two out
two strike hit
it's six to five
a lot of holes in the infield places the
ball to fall in out there we're a hit
away from tying this baby up derek
holland on the mound in the sixth inning
jacoby jones sends one to deep center
field and that's gone
jacoby jones hits a bomb to center for
home run number four on the year fifth
homer for the tigers today here's miguel
cabrera
popped up
and a chance for evans polanco it's
polanco and both he and evans are down
the out is recorded and jonathan scope
is going to score from second
evans has remained down for the
instruction of the medical staff there
he has been moving paramedics are
coming out now
philip evans just hope he's okay
go to the seventh
10-5 detroit teen hits for the tigers
here tonight cj crone
rips one that's a fair ball down the
left field line takes an awkward bounce
cabrera will score
krone follows up cabrera's double with
an rbi two base hit of his own and the
tigers tech on the 11th run of the night
yeah cj we're talking about staying back
he's back and he just unloads